hello everyone
and thank you for attending the solving
large scale inverse problem in python
with pilots
here at pi data global 2020. before we
start i'd like to
thank the organizing committee of phi
data for
creating such a great opportunity for
people to learn
and explore new tools in python and i
hope you'll enjoy
coding with us for the next two hours
i'd like to start by just
briefly guiding you through the main
repository where we have store
all the different notebooks that we are
going to go through today and some of
the solutions
you can easily access this notebook and
uh
navigate through its content and we will
see later
in more details what the different
notebooks are
about before we start
just a few words about the material
that is covered here how you are going
to be able to run it
yourself we are suggesting two possible
solutions
you can either use your local python
installation if you are familiar with
creating a condor virtual environment
and you can follow these instructions
for further installing pilots
instead you can also just use google
collapse and we provide links below you
can click and access directly the
notebooks we're gonna go through in
collab in that case just be aware that
some libraries are missing so we have a
few
uh blogs that you will need to run to
install for example pilots
and also if you wanna access the
solutions we have a different links for
notebooks that include solutions here
are the three instructors today
my name is mateo abazi i work as a
research scientist at ecuador
and we have also david vargas and ivan
vazquez from the university of utrecht
which will guide you through the
next notebooks later on and as i already
said
you can access our notebooks in three
different ways directly from this link
you can see them in github
you can of course clone or download the
repository and access them locally
or you can click this button and you
will be sent directly
into cola before we start with the first
notebook
i'll just like you to give you a very
brief overview
of pilots which is the main library we
are going to use today
and i highly recommend you after the
talk if you start using pilot for your
own
research to go through the documentation
and especially take a a detailed look at
the
api of pilots and all the different
operators and solvers that we offer
because more often than probably you
expect you will see that
some of the problems you want to solve
can be easily solved by combining these
operators without having to write
any new operator or very limited amount
of
code other than using what we already
provide
and let's see with the first
introductory notebook
if you can start to get familiar
and start to use these operators to
solve a few
interesting problems before just to make
sure that we are all on the same page
i would like to have a very brief
theoretical introduction to
a various concepts that will be
recurring today first of all
we're gonna solve inverse problems so we
will see what is an inverse problem
we will also see why and in which
circumstances you would like to use
linear operators to solve inverse
problems
and after this is clear we will see how
we can do that with pilots how we can
set up our own
linear operator from scratch so you will
see actually a bit more about the inner
working of this library
and later how you can use those that are
already available and combined
once again as i already mentioned here
are three
very useful links for you later on a
link of our github repository where you
will find all this
material and the main repository of the
labs library and the reference
documentation you have already seen
so let's start with some theory
i'm expecting you at least to have some
basic understanding of linear algebra
and provided that
you should be familiar if you look at
this cartoon to see that
generally we can write a problem or
in this case a linear problem as follows
we have a vector y
that belongs to a space on
dimensionality n
we have a vector x that belongs to a
different space
of possibly different dimensionality we
will say of dimensionality
m and we have an operator a which
in our case is a linear operator and in
even
a simpler way is just a matrix of
dimensionality
n by m which if we apply it to the
vector x
will bring us to the of the vector y
we call this our forward model or
forward operation
conversely we have something that is
called the adjoined modeling or the
adjoint operation and you will see later
why this is very important
and this can be simply written by taking
the matrix
and applying the adjoint which means
applying the
transpose of the metrics so we transpose
the matrix
as you can see we take this two three by
two matrix into a two by three
and we put all the elements that we add
on the columns of the rows and vice
versa and also we apply the complex
conjugate
now if we apply this a joint matrix to
the vector y
we will get a vector x so in simplest
form i've been talking about a as a
matrix but you will see that
in most cases for real life problems
these metrics will be too big
to either be story memory and definitely
to
make operations with it for example to
invert it
that's where the concept of linear
operators comes in and this
is very simply stated as follows a
linear operator is just
a pair of pieces of code
one that allows you to implement these
operations so
taking a vector x as input applies the
effect of the operator or the matrix a
and gives you a vector y
on the other end taking the vector y
the adjoined pieces of joint piece of
code will apply
the joint operator and will give you a
vector x
finally since we are interested to solve
inverse problems
uh what we are most interested in is to
invert the matrix a or do that to the
best of our capabilities
and apply it to the vector y to get an
estimate of x
we will see how this is in practice
mostly done by iterative solvers
and one of the advantages of iterative
solvers is that they do not require to
know
each of the entries of the metrics of
the operator a
you only need to know how you apply it
in a forward and near joint mode
and that's where as i already said the
concept of linear operator can see
so we have now hopefully a basic
understanding and
let's see what happens if we start uh
going through
one simple case the adam are product
which we can also refer to as the
element-wise multiplication
so the multiplication of two different
vectors
and we will see how we can implement
this straight using
numpy and using for example dense
matrixes to mimic this operation
and also how we can do that with pylons
so to start we just gonna import our
usual
uh libraries that we are gonna need
mostly in this case will be numpy
sci pi and pilots and microlib
some of the plotting and let's have a
look how we will write an element-wise
multiplication
element-wise multiplication can be very
simply
written in this compact form you say we
take each element of the vector x
multiplied by each element of a vector d
and then we get
the corresponding element of the vector
y if we were to see this
as a matrix vector formulation because
this is what we want to do to be able to
create a linear operator
and then post simulator chain this
operation with other
uh operations that will create maybe a
more interesting
forward modelling at the end we see that
the diagonal this sorry the element was
multiplication can be also seen
as a diagonal matrix which contains the
elements of this vector d along the main
diagonal
multiplied by the vector x in this case
we can just
uh on pen and paper perform the
transpose of these metrics and the
complex conjugate and we get what we
call the adjoint
so we see from permanent paper how we
can implement the forward
and the adjoint now how are we going to
do this
uh in practice let's start
assuming that we want to do this with
dense matrixes
for example with using numpy so what we
can do we just say we have a vector
diag that contains uh n elements
in this case from zero to nine we use
the np diag
method of numpy to take this vector a
along
inside the matrix of size n 10 by 10 and
place the vector along the main diagonal
and then we will have zero everywhere
else now we want to apply the forward
this is very easy
because we can create a vector x that's
in this case take a vector of once
we use np dot past the
matrix and the vector and we get the
output
y which is the forward modeling
operation
we want to also do this with the adjoint
and in this case it's very easy because
we have access directly to the metrics
we can simply transpose it with the dot
t
we apply the complex conjugation even
though in this case it's
not really needed because we are dealing
with real numbers and then we apply
again np dot
now on the vector y and this is what we
get
so this is possible and easy why do we
want to
complicate our life and start to use
linear operators well before we even do
that
let's try to look a bit at the
limitations of this approach
everything seems easy but we have two
limitations the first we are storing n
square numbers in our metrics even
though we know that the matrix is
diagonal and only
the elements along the diagonal are
really the elements that we are
interested in also we are applying a dot
product
which requires n square multiplication
and summations but again
most of them will be with zeros of
course we can
in this case use sparse matrixes like
those for example that
scipio first and we will go a long way
but i'm asking you to just
have some faith and we're gonna try to
see how we can write this as a linear
operator and we'll see later that this
will bring benefit
over also over sparse matrices we're
gonna do this
uh using the notation of uh pilots
so that you already get familiar with
how we're going to implement
we can implement an operator in pilots
and this is done
as follows we just define a class
we give it a name and we sub classes to
the linear operator
pilot's parent class which is already
pretty much taking inheritance from the
sci-fi linear operator
to which we have added some additional
interesting methods and properties that
you will see later on
to do the actual implementation we only
need to create
and implement three different functions
they need function like in any
other class in python and then we have
the so-called map
back underscore attack and underscore
our modpack
underscore matrix performs a forward
underscore argument vector force the
adjoint
and you will see that we are never gonna
call this directly we will have some
overload on some more
mathematically nicely looking symbols
but this is what we need to implement so
how are we going to do it
in this case is very simple we can just
pass our diagonal vectors
store it in our self diag
and then when it comes to the forward
they are joined we just
apply it to the vector x with the
star and since both of them will be
numpy raise this will be an element wise
multiplication
and when it comes to the adjoint we can
simply apply the complex conjugate as
you have seen in the equations both
and then we apply again the star
two more things that we need to discuss
before we move on are these two
members of our class the member shape
and a memory
these two are always required the first
one because we need to tell
our code and eventually pilots what is
the size of the operator i'm not
creating remember anymore a dense
metrics not even a sparse metrics in
this case
so eventually the code is not aware of
what is the size of our operator
and we need to tell it in this case this
is very easy because this is just the
length of the vector diag both for the
space motor space and data space
and also we want to define a type a d
type
which we have set as default as float64
and this is because
in some more complicated operators for
example dealing with complex and real
numbers we want to make sure that
within the mat back in our modpack
pieces of code
we don't do some unwanted recasting of
our input vectors and our two vectors
let's now
run this cell and see how we can call
this operator we can
simply say diagonal pass or diag
numpy vector and then if we print it we
see
that this is a 10 by 10 diagonal
operator which has this d
type now are we going to apply it
we can do it with a forward and as i
already said before we don't really need
to access the
underscore attack we can use the star or
alternatively also the x symbol
and if we run this set we see we get the
same result as before
and now we are not creating the metrics
we have just
defined a piece of code that applies
this operation
same for the adjoint now we have the dot
h
that tells pylops or in this case
uh tells our implementation that we want
to apply the adjoint
and only at the point where we have the
star we are really
applying the adjoint and this is the
vector x
h that looks like the exact same as
before
so now it's time for the first exercise
that you can
go through yourself and later on we can
discuss
in the q and a session what i'm asking
to do is to make now this vector x and y
much bigger
and see how these two implementations
compare and as a bonus if you want you
can also try using
psi pi sparse matrices as a third way of
implementing
this diagonal or element-wise
multiplication
before we move on to a second operator
which is a bit more interesting and also
be more challenging so
uh we'll hopefully give you a bit more
understanding of the
value and also how we implement linear
operators in practice
we need to understand how to test our
two pieces of code we have
in this case written our four on their
joint how do we really know that they
are correct how do we know that
before when they are joined they are
actually doing what their
explicit metrics or implementation will
do
and we know that if this is not the case
iterative solvers will generally diverge
we will see instabilities and in some
special lucky cases
we may still conversions to solution but
we will see a slow convergence
luckily there is something called the
dot test that allows us to test the
validity of
our two implementations if you're
familiar with lineal algebra you can see
that if we start from this equation on
the left
we have our operator a now we have two
vectors
u and v which are we can just draw
random
vectors one of dimensionality
m and the other one of dimensionality n
if we now apply the forward
we get the vector of dimensionality n
sorry and we then perform the dot
product
with the vector v and we get the scalar
now let's use some simple linear algebra
we know that
if we have the adjoint or a transpose of
a product of a matrix of a vector
this can be written as swapping
a and u and applying the adjoint to each
of them
later we use the associative property of
the
dot product same as the multiplication
for scalars
and we can rewrite this equation in this
form so now we have uh
that is applied to a vector that we have
created
as the application of the adjoint to a
vector v
so what we see here is that we have now
the possibility on the right to apply
our drawing piece of code and on the
left the four
piece of code and only if this equality
is verified
we have guaranteed ourselves that what
we have done is correct
so in pilots we can simply access these
using the dot test method
we pass the operator its dimensionality
and in this case we are saying that we
want it to be verbose so we see
some uh printing of the actual scalars
that we get
and also that the test is passed
now let's move to as i said something a
bit more interesting
the first derivative let's imagine you
have a signal
in this case a discretized vector that
is representing a
line with slope one we want to apply the
first derivative and we know that the
derivative of y equal x
is e y equal one we also know that we
can do this numerically
if we have discretized this function as
a vector x
by taking each element of the vector a
step
i plus 1 also at step
i minus 1 subtracting them and dividing
by 2 times assembly and this gives us
the value
of the vector y at location i
we can assuming that the delta is equal
one we can simply write this again
in our matrix vector formulation
and this is how the matrix will look
like and if we now
pen and paper apply their join this is
how their joint will look like
so now you can look at these two
different matrixes
and you can think about or start
thinking about how you would implement
this as a linear operator as i said
already before you don't need to write a
matrix
and in this case i'm going to give you a
couple of ins
you could use as like the slicing
properties for example of numpy
or you can see the forward and they are
joined as a pair of convolutional
correlation with a
with a small compact filter i'm going to
give you an exercise and asking you to
implement it
but for now we will just take
the dense metrics implementation
which is creating again using np diag
and doing a bit of
uh small changes at the edges
to allow implementing a first order
forward the backward
derivatives instead of the center
derivative and we're going to skip
all the way to using directly the
pilops implementation so we can just use
pilots a dot for derivative as
the length of the input vector and we
also use this
edge equal to which will do the same as
the edges as we have done in the
explicit matrix
we now run the dot test and we see that
the dot test will be passed
now let's take a vector x that goes from
minus
five to five with step one so
analytically this is a y equal x
uh function like we have in the drawing
above
and we know that if we apply the forward
either way as
a dot product of the matrix d times the
vector x
or using helps the ops the op operator
forward operator we should get
a vector y that is a vector of one and
that's what we get
similarly the adjoint we have done it
already
before we can just do np dot
on the transpose we know this matrix is
only real numbers
or we can use the d op dot h of pilots
and again we get the same result so we
have proven that we can do
uh this uh first order derivative in two
different ways with
dense metrics and also using the concept
of linear operators
once again to understand the value of
linear operators i'm asking you to do
these two exercises
the first one is the same as before
let's just make the vectors bigger and
see
how these two implementations compare in
terms of computational cost
and the second one is also to look at
the actual memory footprint
at the matrix d as well as the operator
deal
and you will see hopefully if you get
through these two exercises the benefits
of using linear operators for both of
these
two aspects of our implementation
but finally what is more important is
not really
being able to perform for one at your
joint that's nice but what we are
generally interested in science is to
solve the underlying inverse problems so
given a vector
y which has some observations that we
can
physically record giving our knowledge
of a forward problem in this case
the matrix d or the operator v o how can
we get an estimate of the
vector x and here we are comparing two
different possible waves
once we have an explicit matrix we can
use the
ls tsq method of
psi pi which will apply or solve the
least square problem
using a direct solver and we can also
use the backslash that we have
implemented in pilops as a shorthand
which we'll call uh scipy sparse
linux lsqr solver or depending on the
size of the matrix if the method c
squared will call conjugate gradient
we run these two and we see that we get
the same result
sorry that went not where i was
expecting
we see we get the same result from minus
5 back to 5
for both the forward sorry the numpy
implementation
and the bilox implementation last
but not least before we move on to a
second tutorial
is how can we chain operators let's try
to make a problem this problem will be
more interesting we now say that we have
a signal for example a step function and
our recording system
is actually able to only record a
smooth derivative of this input signal
so if we apply the derivative we get a
spike
if we smooth it for example with a
filter of
five samples we get a smooth version or
a small box box car how can we solve
this problem
so far we have seen all the time we
could implement pylops operators
one by one from scratch but what is the
i would say most powerful property of
this library is that we can combine
uh basic or core operators to create
something a bit more interesting like
here a smooth derivative
we can sum operator multiply them we can
even put them
into a chain for example put them stack
them vertically or stack them
horizontally
or put them into a block or block
diagonal fashion
and let's see how we do that for this
example
again we create just a vector x which is
pretty much mimicking the ep side
function that we have seen above we now
perform the
creation of the first derivative as we
have done before so this is the op first
derivative operator
and we also use polylab smoothing 1d
with a
smoothing of 5 samples we can now chain
them with a star
we have seen already above that the star
before was used to
multiply an operator to a numpy vector
and that would have triggered a forward
operator
in this case the star will just lazily
combine them
chain them tell pilots that whenever we
apply this operator
up uh the forward will have to apply
this operator first and then this on the
result of the first operation and the
adjoint will do it the other way around
with error joints so we now create a
data and again invert it
and here uh i will not spend much time
but
uh with pylops we have also access to
more advanced solvers for example we can
solve this
by solving its normal equations with
some ticon or regularization and you
will see later in the next tutorial much
more on this
let's run this cell and you see how very
quickly
we get our data and we get our model
which is inverted and is pretty much
down to numerical procedure the same as
the input
model and this gives us the
end of the first tutorial we have
learned how to translate in operator
from pen and paper to computer code
we have seen how to write them from
scratch
but also how is important to be aware of
all of
the already available zoo of operators
in pilots now they can be combined
and eventually use cnx tutorials our
combining operator will bring you
a long way